bonjour nous sommes en direct ce jeudi
pour vous parler de momie et oui nous
parlonside puisque notre journaliste
Vincent brunoeuvre signe ce jeudi un
article sur la jeunesse éternelle des
momies le secret vous êtes Ternel qui a
été dévoilé c'est sa Vincent bonjour
bonjour exactement il s'agit d'un
article lié dans la revue Nature
hier soir donc
il est assez important même très
important dans pour le pour les la
communauté des égyptologues ça faisait
quelques temps enfin en 2016 pour
raconter la Genèse un archéologue
égyptien très célèbre qui est décédé
depuis et qui consigne cette ces travaux
mais qui est mort malheureusement au
printemps dernier qui s'appelle Ramadan
ucène qui est un des très grandes
archéologues de contemporain avait mis
au jour tout un atelier de momification
sur le site de Sakara qui est quelques
dizaines de kilomètres au sud au sud du
Caire c'est une très grande nécropole
c'est un site qui est très connu
fouiller depuis très longtemps par par
les égyptologues et les fou ont été
particulièrement relancé dans les années
70 donc régulièrement il y a des
découvertes des nouveaux sarcophages des
nouvelles momies il y a il se passe pas
une fasse pas même un mois sans qu'il y
ait quelque chose soit trouver là-bas le
covid avec bien entendu et donc une
communication très forte de la part du
gouvernement égyptien on sait que c'est
quelque chose de sensible là-bas cette
histoire là parce qu'elle fait vivre le
tourisme qui économiquement est très
important et donc en 2016 c'est une
équipe d'archéologues archéologues
d'archéologue a mis au jour cet atelier
et en voyant ça l'ensemble de la
communauté c'est dit on a enfin quelque
chose enfin d'exceptionnel parce que on
est dans le contexte même c'est à dire
qu'on est tel quel tel que ça pouvait
l'être il y a plus de 2000 ans quand les
quand les prêtres utilisaient
utilisaient ce lieu et on va avoir donc
avec des analyses futures la composition
des produits chimiques qui pouvait y
avoir dans les jars parce qu'on a trouvé
beaucoup de contenant de en céramique
dedans et comprendre un peu le mécanisme
de ces modifications et essayer d'aller
un peu plus loin sur sur le rituel et
trois ans cinq ans avant on est en 2023
donc 7 ans après
ces travaux ont tenues toutes leurs
promesses vu que la les résultats ont
été publiés hier donc c'est une équipe
internationale avec deux scientifiques
français à l'intérieur il faut le noter
même si l'un d'entre eux travaillent
aujourd'hui en Allemagne qui ont
présenté en fait l'analyse chimique et
chromatique de l'ensemble de ces de ces
produits chimiques qui étaient contenus
donc dans dans les récipients en
céramique ont été mises à jour et ce qui
permet c'est là c'est en ça que ces
travaux sont extraordinaires d'avoir une
vision beaucoup plus globale de la
momification parce que jusqu'à
maintenant on a régulièrement des
papiers qui sortent avec les recettes
des momies mais qui sont centrés sur un
seul individu là on est dans un atelier
en tant que tel donc on a une vision
plus large et on sait que c'est quelque
chose extrêmement complexe la
modification qui est pas forcément égale
en fonction des catégories sociales et à
des individus et donc on a l'ensemble du
matériel qui avait un prêtre en bonheur
à l'époque égyptienne à l'époque du on
est on est
dynastie donc on est entre -600 et moins
500 avant Jésus-Christ selon notre
calendrier
mais ce qui est important c'est que la
mobilité c'est quelque chose de très
très ancré dans la société égyptienne
depuis le quatrième millénaire parce que
l'Egypte c'est toujours très compliqué
on voit ça comme un tour rétréci un peu
comme comme l'Empire romain mais c'est
extrêmement long il y a plus de temps
qui qui sépare la fin de la période
égyptienne
au début que qui ne sait pas quasiment
de de notre époque à nous et donc
la mobification est restée quand même
assez stable à partir du du de la fin du
début du deuxième millénaire la fin du
troisième et donc on a une constance et
donc cet atelier quand même d'avoir une
une bonne idée de ce qui de comment on
momifier les les gens pendant une grande
partie de de l'époque égyptienne
d'accord je salue Fred qui vient de me
rejoindre vu des gradins publics c'est
passionnant vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr
à poser vos questions on y répond avec
vous n'hésitez pas donc déjà on trouve
encore des choses parce que Didier
depuis les années 70 en fait ces sites
sont enfin il faut se rendre compte de
ce que ça représente c'est utiliser en
terme de période les chips c'est
extrêmement long c'est 2000 3000 ans
plus que c'est plus ça dure si on va
jusqu'à Cléopâtre qui est contemporaine
de Jules César on est sur plus de 4000
ans quoi en commençant avec le début des
dynasties égyptiennes avec plusieurs
périodes là on est juste après la
période des pharaons noirs on est dans
une période qui est paradoxalement assez
mal renseigné c'est à dire que quand moi
je posais la question aux auteurs et à
des égyptologues que j'ai pu avoir en
parallèle pour avoir leur avis sur
l'étude et que je demandais quel pharaon
célèbre
dirigé à cette époque là qu'est-ce qu'on
connaît on avait du mal à me donner des
et même en les gens que j'ai vu on
n'avaient pas forcément c'est bien la
preuve qu'on est dans une période
à mal renseigné c'est assez logique
parce que il y avait des cultures à
l'époque avec mais c'est très compliqué
de retrouver des des sources et donc on
connaît par bride cette période très
très longue avec des moments des points
forts je pense à Ramsès II par exemple
qui est Milan avant avant cette
découverte donc c'est extrêmement large
et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on a un peu
du mal à mesurer c'est cette cette
étendue étendue de la période de la
période égyptienne et donc là on est
dans une période un peu creuse d'un
point de vue historique ça veut pas dire
qu'il se passe qui se passe rien au
contraire c'est découverte monde qui a
énormément de choses et on y reviendra
après
donc donc voilà je sais plus où j'en
étais mais
voilà un truc 5 et 500 et 400 moi
Jésus-Christ d'accord alors sur sur ce
qui a été découvert c'est en fait alors
moi j'ai baptisé c'est la recette de
exactement pour pour réussir une belle
momie il faut faire ça exactement
c'est la recette des ingrédients en fait
après toute la difficulté c'est que il
faut croiser ces découvertes avec des
sources écrites mais il y a aussi un
savoir-faire qui est sans doute pas
c'est pas si facile que ça bon pour
faire une momie c'est un processus très
long qui mêle à la fois des dérites
religieux des prières et des des
procédés plus en moins chimiques des
manipulations des corps on va extraire
les organes pour pas qu'ils pourrissent
et encore une fois ça ne fait pas
forcément à toutes les périodes et on le
fait pas à tout le monde à partir du du
deuxième millénaire il me semble on est
se crée on est on extrait aussi le
cerveau à l'aide de de crochet mais ça
on l'a pas fait à toutes les époques et
encore une fois on le fait pas on le
fait pas à tout le monde donc là ce
qu'on a c'est le récipient et les
produits qu'utilisés qu'utilisaient les
les prêtres en bonheur ce qui est
vachement important pour les pour les
égyptologues en tout cas c'est que ces
produits étaient connus depuis longtemps
dans les papyrus mais on avait des
hiéroglyphes qui design on savait pas
trop ce que ça voulait dire notamment
deux qui sont au cœur de ces travaux qui
sont Lancelot et le cfaite qui sont deux
produits qu'on traduisés par en dessous
et c'est fait on imaginait qu'il y avait
des instances dedans mais on avait du
mal à comprendre c'était des concepts et
là ces concepts deviennent réalité parce
qu'on a des analyses chimiques qui nous
permettent de nous rendre compte ce que
il y avait une il y avait tout
simplement un pot avec marqué en dessous
un autre avec marqué ses fêtes mais il y
en a plusieurs et on a pu analyser se
rendre compte qu'elle était leur
composition et donc on voit que c'est
des compositions complexes avec
différentes essais avec différentes
essences notamment du cyprès des des
essences qu'on trouve beaucoup autour du
bassin méditerranéen et ce qui a surpris
un peu les auteurs c'est que ces deux
produits a été très proche à leur
composition chimique légèrement
différentes c'est à dire qu'on va plus
s'équilibrer avec plus d'huile de
visites végétales dans un autre
et en plus des noms sur les pots il y
avait aussi les consignes à conduire à
enduire la tête avec enduire le corps
etc et maintenant ce qu'il faut réussir
à comprendre c'est à quel moment on
mettait tant dans le tuyau à quel moment
on mettait tant de ces fêtes avec quel
avec quel autre essence on allait on
allait mélanger tout ça et donc ça c'est
c'est un travail d'analyse sur
l'ensemble des papyrus de répertorier
qui va permettre d'avoir une idée un peu
plus un peu plus précise mais on a mis
des noms sur des étiquettes et ça c'est
quand même déjà extrêmement important et
on a la compréhension et ça c'est la
deuxième volet de cette étude de
l'importance qui avait la momification
dans dans le système égyptien mais on le
savait parce que on a quand même des
découvertes extraordinaires mais pour
amener l'ensemble de ces produits il
faut un commerce qui va derrière parce
que le ski ce qui constitue l'antio et
le fait normalement il vient pas très
loin mais vient du pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen donc il va arriver le
chercher il fallait avoir des accords
commerciaux pour pouvoir faire faire ça
et au vu du nombre de momies il y avait
quand même une production très
importante
la mort c'est quand même ce qui est
éternel dans l'ensemble des
civilisations et ce qui c'est notre
point commun à tous et donc c'est une
industrie qu'il faut qu'il faut faire
fonctionner donc il y avait une économie
une économie derrière effectivement je
salue vu des gradins qui me dit il me
semble qu'il est moins de temps entre
nous et Cléopâtre quand Cléopâtre et la
création des pyramides c'est ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure exactement
mais merci beaucoup d'être là on va
continuer de parler de de sujets donc il
y a encore des choses à apprendre il
commence qu'est-ce qu'on a appris
justement sur les gens qui tout le monde
se faisait momifier ou c'est une
question dont on n'a pas forcément la
réponse de manière absolue il semblerait
que que non parce que c'est c'est un
processus que les extrêmement long
extrêmement coûteux je parlais de des
produits qui venaient du bassin
méditerranéen on a aussi trouvé on y
reviendra peut-être tout à l'heure des
produits qui venaient encore plus loin
qui qui posent un certain nombre de
questions mais il y avait sans doute
différents degrés de momification en
fonction de son social je rappelle que
le but de la momification c'est préparé
à l'au-delà c'est de faire du de notre
enveloppe charnelle une divinité pour
pour le monde pour le monde après
d'après la mort
et donc la modification elle est du
simple desséchage du corps
une modification un peu naturelle donc
on entretenait dans dans ces espèces de
laboratoires
qu'on retrouve qu'on a pu retrouver ici
jusqu'à cet amendement avec les
bandelettes et tout tout ce que on
connaît dans la mythologie contemporaine
mais c'est bandelettes c'est ce qu'on
c'est ce qui ressort c'est ce qu'on voit
dans les films dessus de fantastique
c'est ce qui existe dans la mythologie
mais en fait nous on s'intéresse aux
bandelettes parce qu'elles sont
spectaculaires et c'est ce que disent
les auteurs ce qui est sans doute plus
intéressant c'est les enduits qu'on
mettait le plus proche du corps parce
que comme il touchait l'enveloppe il
devait avoir une importance
une importance
je perds mes mots en tout cas il va
avoir symbolique voilà une importance
symbolique beaucoup plus importante que
que laver que n'avait des bandelettes et
c'est en ça que que cette étude est très
et très intéressante parce que on se
rend compte de ce degré différent dans
les dans l'espace de la société
gyptienne avec ses mixture qui sont
là-bas et le fait et puis des choses
beaucoup plus rares et donc ce que j'ai
tout à l'heure on a notamment retrouvé
du Damart le Damart c'est une résine qui
aujourd'hui ne se trouve que en Asie du
Sud-Est et notamment en Indonésie si je
me trompe pas de doit être soit elle
était présente en Egypte ancienne dans
ces zones là soit il fait jusqu'à
l'Égypte ça ressemble peu probable et
soit elle pourrait être présente en
Afrique mais quoi qu'il arrive ça
implique des
routes commerciales très longues et
alors il y a deux possibilités donc sur
en Afrique soit soit en Asie en Asie du
Sud-Est et ce qui est ce qui est hyper
intéressant du coup parce qu'on est
quand même sur des sur des distances
géographiques très importantes alors
c'est pas la première fois on a qu'on a
des découvertes comme ça il se trouve
que dans le sarcophage de Ramsès 2 donc
il date de 1000 ans avant avancer
découverte donc Milan c'est énorme
on était en l'an 1000 en France donc on
parle de quelque chose qui semble du
même civilisation mais avec un million
d'intervalle on a retrouvé
on a retrouvé c'était en 2012 j'ai un
petit trou là on a retrouvé des du tabac
alors le tabac on en trouve quasiment
qu'en Amérique car on peut en trouver
aussi possiblement en Asie en Asie
sud-est et là aussi ça pose une question
est-ce qu'il y avait des transferts avec
des îles très lointaines les les
hypothèses sont sont ouvertes on exclut
pas aussi pour un MC2 la possibilité
d'une contamination parce que le
sarcophage a été conservé dans le musée
du Louvre
dans le musée du Louvre dans le musée du
Caire excusez-moi dans le musée du Caire
et dans lequel on pouvait plus fumer que
qu'on le fait aujourd'hui donc du tabac
qui s'est déposé donc on s'est dit mais
en tout cas la question la question
demeure et la découverte de Damart dans
un cas présent
relance ce type de débat jusqu'où les
Égyptiens pouvaient commercer pour pour
leur mort et ce qui est d'autant plus
intéressant ici c'est que cet atelier
semble pas être un atelier Royal parce
que je disais on a on a un sacara qui
est le l'année propole de Memphis qui a
été capitale de l'Egypte à plusieurs
périodes mais pas au moment où on
fouille pas un moment par moment on
parle la capitale est à Saïs qui est
dans le delta le delta du nid donc
beaucoup plus au nord donc on n'a pas
embaumé de Pharaon dans cet atelier
pourtant on a déjà des essences
extrêmement rares donc il y a le Damart
mais il y en a aussi une autre j'ai pris
le papier ici parce que j'avais peur
d'oublier le le nom qui est
[Musique]
les limites je crois et je retrouve pas
ici que il suffit que je cherche pas le
trouver qui se trouve la même manière en
Asie sud-est et on en a trouvé aussi un
peu en Afrique du Sud donc c'est pour ça
dans le sud de l'Afrique c'est pour ça
que la
le mystère est un peu moins épais que
pour que pour le Damart mais il n'en
demeure pas moins que ça témoigne
d'échange très lointain effectivement
est-ce que du coup maintenant on
pourrait faire on va dire de la
momification comme comme à l'époque
maintenant qu'on sait comment ça marche
et les limites et bien ça alors on
pourrait mais ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est bon on a une idée des
composés chimiques de ces produits on a
les recettes dans un certain nombre de
de papyrus donc ça c'est c'est important
donc on a deux choses mais il y a aussi
un savoir-faire et un savoir-faire et à
sans doute une transmission orale
qu'aujourd'hui on on a perdu par
définition
peut-être que en réutilisant les mêmes
produits à partir des papyrus on va
réussir à trouver ce savoir-faire mais
il faudra quand même un certain nombre
de temps il faut former des gens
avec des sources qui sont quand même
très anciennes ils sont très
parcellaires c'est à dire qu'il manque
encore beaucoup beaucoup d'informations
mais en tout cas on le comprend mieux et
on sait quels éléments étaient utilisés
et il y a quelque chose qu'on entend pas
parler encore qui est l'importance des
odeurs c'est des produits c'est des
essences qui sont extrêmement dents et
il y a quand même aussi l'idée donc non
seulement il y a une propriété chimique
qui permet de garder le corps dans un
état tel qu'il est enfin tu es
incroyable et on le voit encore
aujourd'hui avec les différentes momies
que qu'on a pu découvrir et qui sont
exposés dans les différents musées du
monde mais il y a aussi ce cette idée de
d'apparat pour les yeux avec l'idée de
d'être à jeudi physiquement donc c'est
pour ça qu'on mettait du henné notamment
mais aussi de sentir bon de de
porter de porter quelque chose de
d'extrêmement symbolique alors qu'est-ce
qui nous reste aujourd'hui du coup à
découvrir c'est ça c'est cette
transmission orale il reste encore
beaucoup de choses à faire non non il y
a un scénario à découvrir veut dire que
il y a un certain nombre de
d'essence par exemple qui sont qualifiés
ici dans ces travaux des sens végétales
c'est à dire qu'il y a peut-être encore
des des précisions à avoir sur quel
végétal qu'elle lui de quel oui il
s'agissait l'huile de lin par exemple
est très volatile alors qu'elle était
très très utilisée donc il y a ces
éléments à ses éléments là et puis
on se dit on a un atelier à une période
donnée qui est assez révélateur parce
qu'il permet d'avoir une idée du du d'un
contexte assez large parce que pour la
première fois on étudie donc un atelier
non pas une momie mais bon l'Egypte
c'est très les gypsens c'est pas très
très long donc il faudrait réussir à
trouver des ateliers au début la
momification ça a mis du temps à
s'installer on sait quelque chose qui
est ancré qui a toujours été là mais il
y a une perfection et il a fallu quand
même attendre un millier d'années avant
d'arriver à un système aussi parfait que
que celui qui est qui est qui est
détaillé ici donc
ne serait-ce que cette mise en route
cette comment est-ce que
ce savoir-faire c'est propager pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a utilisé tel produit
plutôt que tel autre là il s'agit par
exemple aussi de comprendre à quel
moment est-ce qu'on va utiliser du
cfaite ou de l'anti ou pourquoi est-ce
qu'on va mélanger les deux pourquoi
est-ce que pour un taille a marqué à
utiliser seulement pour la tête et
plutôt que sur le ventre donc tout ça
c'est les travaux encore qui qui doit
être fait donc c'est des analyses
chimiques bien entendu sur à la fois des
momies à la fois dans dans des
récipients mais aussi en confrontant ça
aux sources écrites et aux manuscrits
qui peuvent qui peuvent exister Monsieur
Jean baguette dans les dans les
commentaires qui nous dit allez voir le
tombeau de Vix en France c'est une tombe
qui date des années -600 mais du coup je
pense qu'il n'y a pas de momie
que c'est un c'est autre chose mais
c'est un site extraordinaire là la
vallée où a été trouvée la princesse de
Vix non c'est pas c'est pas une momie
c'est c'est
elle a une très belle tia notamment
il y a un archéologue notamment celui
qui a découvert vice qui pense que c'est
la Vallée des Rois l'équivalent de la
Vallée des Rois en Europe il y a assez
des tumulus donc c'est justement ces
espèces de collines qui sont rendus
invisibles à l'oeil nu parce que
recouvert de verdure mais c'est c'est
vraiment un site un site extraordinaire
il n'y a pas le même savoir faire le
symbolique avec la mort est pas
forcément le même en Europe on a quand
même remarqué des tombeaux majestueux
c'est quatre vis ou elle était elle
était elle était enterrée avec beaucoup
de de fastes donc je disais cette tiers
en or et il y a un bouclier aussi il me
semble j'ai des trous je crois que
effectivement je vois enfin je vois sur
les images parce que moi je triche
c'est un très beau c'est un très beau un
très beau mais honnêtement on n'est pas
dans quelque chose de comparable le le
en tout cas de ce qu'on sait des sources
écrites et même des données
archéologiques le rôle de la mort dans
la société dans les sociétés 7 était pas
même que dans la société égyptienne et
et alors des des momies il peut en
exister aussi ailleurs qu'en Égypte oui
oui alors il y en a beaucoup en Amérique
latine
précolombienne
on a pu en trouver dans dans en Asie
aussi il me semble mais il y a deux
types de momie il y a des momifications
qui sont naturels c'est un corps qui se
dessèche à un contexte
environnemental climatique il va
favoriser la conservation du corps et il
y a cette industrie donc en Amérique
précolombienne on tout le monde connaît
Tintin oui ça vient de là voilà enfin
c'est pas une source historique mais
dans notre imaginaire c'est quand même
quelque chose qui compte ce que je t'ai
raconté là c'est c'est une réalité il y
avait vraiment des des momies il y en a
plein d'autres un Star capack etc
mais
mais on n'est pas quand même à ce niveau
de savoir-faire en tout cas de ce que
nous disent les sources alors peut-être
qu'on est passé à côté quelque chose et
que il faut quand même toujours avoir en
tête que quand on parle archéologie a
toujours ce biais des fouilles des chips
c'est fouillé depuis très longtemps il y
a les pyramides visibles qui sont
attirés on sait où trouver les choses
c'est donc donc il y a quand même cette
émoi là qui est très qui est très
important mais ce qui semble d'après ces
sources c'est que le rôle de la mort se
passa d'un monde à l'autre c'est quand
même assez
assez unique dans dans les civilisations
qu'on connaît de la civilisation et
égyptienne très bien merci beaucoup
Vincent d'avoir avec nous merci à vous
d'avoir été nombreux à nous suivre la
suite du programme sur Figaro live ce
sera le buzz TV à partir de 17h 17h30 ce
sera la question du jour je recevrai
Emma Ferrand du viro étudiant 18h point
de vue avec Damien cadiez et à 20h le
club idéal bonne soirée Sophie alive